>>> FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP IS RETURNING TO THE CPAC
STAGE TOMORROW.
HIDE THE FLAGS.
♪♪
SO DISTURBING.
AND NOW THE SAME MAN WHO GRIPPED
THE STARS AND STRIPES WON'T LET
GO OF SOMETHING ELSE.
THE IDEA THAT HE'S STILL
PRESIDENT.
JUST LOOK AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE HE HELD THIS WEEK,
THE FLAGS, THE COLUMNS, THAT
VAGUELY FAMILIAR SEAL ON THE
PODIUM.
OF COURSE THAT'S NOT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THAT'S TRUMP'S GOLF CLUB AT
BEDMINSTER BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
SOME KIND OF POTUS POTEMKIN
VILLE WITH TMP AS THE
PRETENDER IN CHIEF.
YES, HE SEEMS TO BE SPENDING HIS
POST-PRESIDENCY PLAYING
PRESIDENT.
AND AS ALWAYS, HE IS PLAYING THE
VICTIM TOO.
THIS TIME CLAIMING
DISINFORMATION IS BEING DIRECTED
AT HIM.
>> IF YOU SAY IT LONG ENOUGH,
HARD ENOUGH, OFTEN ENOUGH,
PEOPLE WILL START TO BELIEVE IT.
>> YEAH.
AND WITH TRUMP, PROJECTION IS
ALWAYS PART OF THE PERFORMANCE.
AND OVER ON FOX NEWS, HIS GANDI.
>> I WAS STRUCK BY THE
PRESIDENTIAL PRESENTATION AT
BEDMINSTER, THE THRONGS OF
REPORTERS, THE ENTOURAGE IN THE
BACKGROUND, THE ONLY THING THAT
WAS MISSING WAS THE PRESIDENTIAL
SEAL ON THE PODIUM.
>> AND IT LOOKED LIKE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> I FORGOT WHO WAS PRESIDENT
ALL OF A SUDDEN, GOOD TO SEE HIM
BACK IN ACTION.
>> YES, BECAUSE IT'S ALL JUST AN
ACADEMY, YOU MIGHT SAY HIS
SECOND ACT.
TRUMP HOPPED ON A PLANE TO THE
TEXAS GOFF BORDER, MET WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND HOUSE REPUBLICANS,
AND GAVE INSTRUCTIONS ABOUT THE
WALL'S PAINT JOB.
IT WAS LIKE OLD TIMES, AS TRUMP
REVIVED HIS WISHES TO PAINT THE
WALL BLACK SO THE HOT BORDER SUN
WILL SCALD ANYONE WHO TRIES TO
CLIMB IT.
>> THEY HAVE TO PAINT IT.
IF THEY DON'T PAINT IT, BAD
THINGS ARE HAPPENING.
THE BEST COLOR TO PAINT IT IS
BLACK BECAUSE IF YOU PAINT IT
BLACK, IT'S SO HOT, NOBODY CAN
EVEN TRY TO CLIMB IT.
>> ALL THAT WAS MISSING THAT DAY
WAS TRUMP PROMISING MEXICO WOULD
PAY FOR IT.
ALSO ON HAND, THE ARCHITECT OF
TRUMP'S IMMIGRATION PLAN,
STEPHEN MILLER, AND FORMER
ACTING SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY CHAD WOLF.
WHAT'S NEXT, ANOTHER STOP THE
STEAL RALLY AT THE WALL?
HE MIGHT FIND SOME OF THE OATH
KEEPERS AND PROUD BOYS ARE IN
JAIL.
CPAC EARLIER THIS YEAR PUT ON
DISPLAY AN ENORMOUS GOLDEN
STATUE OF TRUMP WITH GOLD SHORTS
AND A WAND.
THERE'S NO WAND THAT CAN CHANGE
THE ELECTION RESULTS.
>> YOU CAN SEE HE LOST THE
ELECTION.
BUT HIS SUPPORTERS, 73
MILLION --
>> HE DID LOSE THE ELECTION.
>> HE CAN SAY THAT HE LOST THE
ELECTION.
>> HE DID LOSE THE ELECTION.
>> YEAH, YEAH, BUT I'M
QUIBBLING, OF COURSE HE LOST THE
ELECTION.
>> MAKES MY BRAIN HURT.
THEY'LL NEED MORE REMINDERS
BECAUSE TRUMP KEEPS MAKING THE
ROUNDS TO FLORIDA, NORTH
CAROLINA, OHIO, WHERE SOME OF
HIS FOLLOWERS HAVE CONVINCED
THEMSELVES HE'LL BE REINSTATED.
>> DO YOU GENUINELY BELIEVE --
>> HE'S COMING BACK.
>> -- THAT HE COULD COME BACK AS
SOON AS --
>> BEFORE THE MIDDLE OF AUGUST.
>> WHAT IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN?
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A CIVIL
WAR BECAUSE THE MILITIA WILL BE
TAKEN.
>> EVEN THE CONSPIRACY LOVING
CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE SOUNDED A NOTE OF CAUTION
ABOUT THAT WACKY THEORY, THAT
TRUMP WILL RETURN TO THE WHITE
HOUSE IN AUGUST.
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO BE CAREFUL
IN WHAT THEY BELIEVE.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION.
AND SO I HATE FOR ANYONE TO GET
THEIR HOPES UP THINKING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOING TO BE
BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
AUGUST BECAUSE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
AND I'M TELLING YOU AS A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, THAT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT THING TO MAKE HAPPEN.
>> IT'S NOT JUST VERY DIFFICULT,
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
THERE IS NO CONSTITUTIONAL
MECHANISM THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
IT.
THIS IS THE LAND OF THE FREE,
NOT THE LAND OF THE
MAKE-BELIEVE.
BUT TRUMP LOVES TO PLAY PRETEND.
REMEMBER THIS OLD ACT AT HIS
RALLIES?
>> IT'S A LOT EASIER TO ACT
PRESIDENTIAL THAN TO DO WHAT I
DO.
ANYBODY CAN ACT LIKE A
PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
YOU ARE TREMENDOUS PEOPLE.
AND I WILL LEAVE NOW BECAUSE I
AM BORING YOU TO DEATH.
THANK YOU.
>> TRUMP ACTUALLY HAD IT
BACKWARDS.
IT'S A LOT HARDER TO ACT
PRESIDENTIAL AND EXIT THE STAGE
WITH DIGNITY AND GRACE.
AND PERHAPS SOME HUMILITY.
ON THAT NOTE, THERE IS SOMETHING
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO I COMPARED
TRUMP'S COMEBACK TOUR TO THE
CIRCUS FULL OF SIDESHOW ACTS AND
CLOWNS.
I LATER GOT AN EMAIL FROM AN
EXPERT ON THE CIRCUS INDUSTRY.
THIS PERSON POINTED OUT THAT
COMPARISON ACTUALLY WAS NOT FAIR
BECAUSE UNLIKE THE CHAOS OF
TRUMP WORLD, THE CIRCUS IS
CAREFULLY COMPOSED AND
ORGANIZED.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT.
COMPARING TRUMP TO A CLOWN IS
MOST DEFINITELY AN INSULT TO
CLOWNS.
HE'S MORE LIKE ONE OF THOSE
MASK-HATING CUSTOMERS AT THE
GROCERY STORE.
YOU'VE SEEN THEM.
A KAREN, OR WHATEVER THE NAME
WOULD BE IN TRUMP'S CASE.
YOU CAN ALMOST HEAR HIM SAYING
"I WANT TO TALK TO THE MANAGER
ABOUT THE ELECTION."
OF TWITTER OR FACEBOOK."
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE KIND
OF LIKE THE STORE MANAGER.
WE HAVE TO EXPLAIN, WELL, SIR,
YOU LIED ABOUT THE ELECTION.
YOU INCITED AN INSURRECTION.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LEAVE
THE STORE OR WE'RE CALLING
SECURITY.
PLEASE T